do you know it's a it's one of those
complicated subjects and you're right we
have a lot of experience with a lot of
planners both in London and and around
the country I think it's fair to say
that it's a complicated system it's not
just planning if we look at the kind of
non planning stuff which often can take
nearly as long there's no question in
the UK that that planning process can
often take a long time
years and years sometimes in their
appeal systems which can extend that
having said that I think you know there
is a lot of will from a lot of local
authorities who really want to have more
residential and and the right sort of
other development we find that when when
we're properly engaged with local
authorities and when the communities
that you work with are fully engaged it
can actually be a very beneficial
process so we have a budget next
Wednesday what would you like to see the
chance for announcing you know a lot of
people are going to be looking for
clarity I think that's going to be
helpful we do know that that's hard for
the for the government to provide in
terms of you know in terms of some of
the negotiations they are going to take
a while they are going to be difficult
as you know many people think they'll go
right down to the wire so I think as
much clarity as as possible would be
useful it's clear that he feels he only
has a certain amount of you know leeway
when what he can do but I would have
thought things which are you know
focused on anything around certainty for
business in many different ways would be
good I think you know lack of change
would help people because there's enough
to manage at the moment without finding
some completely new regime suddenly
magic from nowhere so those would be the
things that I particularly would be
looking for I do think there is a lot of
appetite in this country right now to
find ways of helping you know faster
rates of house building for example you
know I've one of the areas that we are
quite interested in in principle is you
know the the rental housing market can
we build more houses in order to create
a rental product for very understandable
reasons the government has been quite
focused on you know helped to buy and I
I think that's fine but
you know we have the opportunity at one
of our big developments down in Canada
water to deliver you know we're
submitting a plan next year to build 650
homes we feel that a rental part of that
would be really appropriate as well of
course as affordable so balancing those
things up could be very powerful could
get more houses built and and frankly
could also end up with has been more
efficient about as you said just now
that's a lot of potential tenants don't
appear to be unduly unnerved by brexit
right now but how do you feel about the
way that the negotiations progress think
you'll counterpart at LAN securities the
other day said that they were moving at
a glacial pace I mean are you frustrated
by that yeah one of the things that we
tried to do ever since the vote was
really try and focus on the things that
we can control and I think that decision
is really a decision but that approach
has served as well because at times like
these they are on sometimes it's easy to
start kind of whinging about things
which at the end of the day are genuine
the outside of our control what we're
finding is that people do want to have
discussions they do want to make
decisions it's been pretty obvious that
this is going to be a really hard thing
to get right and it'll take a while you
know the sooner the better
for sure and I actually think that some
of the conversations in the last you
know almost 24 hours about you know
where you might end up with passports
and how you might make a longer period
of transition and and make sure that
business people can move around the EU
that strikes me as a as a small step in
that in the right direction but that's
that's how we're looking at things right
now